[موسيقى]
we
not بيان صادر
عن القوات المسلحه اليمنيه بسم الله
الرحمن
الرحيم البحر الاحمر خط احمر بالنسبه
لليمنيين الصواريخ مجنحه والابا بالل
المسيره تتجول في الاجواء بانتظار فرسه
لتنقض عليها امريكا تحشد جيوشها وكما يقول
العرب تطلب الفزعه من حلفائها لكن من لبوا
النداء في حرب اوكرانيا هاهم اليوم
يعتذرون قائلين لسنا قادرين على جبال
اليمن ولا على وعوره تضاريسه الكثير من
السفن تخر سريعه في البحر الاحمر وخليج
عدن المدمرات الامريكيه والغواصات
الاستراتيجيه تعلن عن عجزها تجمع الحلفاء
بعد شده ولكن ما هذا التحالف الخجول الذي
كان شرط المنضمين اليه الا لا تكشف
اسماؤهم او تظهر اعلام دولهم الطائرات
البريطانيه والامريكيه تشن مئات الغارات
جوا وبحرا ليتضح فيما بعد ان جميع الاهداف
كانت وهميه وتم هدر الذخيره لم تتوقف
الصواريخ والمسيرات اليمنيه عن الاستهداف
واشنطن تستعين بالتنين الصيني لكبح جماح
ابو اليمن بوتين بتلك الزاويه يضحك
ليقولها بالحضن يا ابو اليمن نعم صنعاء
تمد جسور التحالف بين روسيا وبوتين يمد
يده لليمنيين روسيا ترد الصاع صاعين للغرب
بحرب استنزافها في البحرين الاحمر والعربي
اذا ما تدخلت امريكا وبريطانيا بريا فم
الذي سيحدث امام شعب خاض الكثير من الحروب
عبر التاريخ دون ان يطلب فاصلا لاخذ
انفاسه قاتل العثمانيين وحارب الفرس وتحضر
لقتال جن سليمان فماذا هي فاعله امريكا
امام قوم
هؤلاء الصاروخ اليمني اسرع من توماهوك
امريكا عبرت صواريخ ابو اليمن البالستيه
ومسيرته فوق البحر الاحمر لتقطع مسافه
اكثر من 1700 م وتصل الى اهدافها في مدينه
ايث العبريه هناك اعلنت حكومه صنعاء
مشاركتها في عمليه السابع من اكتوبر يمتلك
الجيش اليمني الكثير من تلك الصواريخ
ابرزها صاروخ طوفان الذي يصل مداه من
1350 م الى
1950 م وكذلك صاروخ قادر الذي يمكن ان يصل
لنحو 1000 ر اي ان العمق العبري هو اساسا
في مرمى صواريخ اليمن ليس ذلك فحسب فمسي
ابو اليمن كشاهد ووعيد يمكن ان يصل مداها
لنحو 2500 ر لتصبح تلبيب ضمن مدى هذه
المسيرات في البحر الاحمر هجم ابو اليمن
السفن العبريه والامريكيه والبريطانيه وكل
سفينه تتبع او تتجه نحو العبريين تعطلت
سلاسل التوريد العالميه وفشلت الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها في رضع الهجمات اليمنيه
فكيف عجزت واشنطن ولندن عن تجنب الهجمات
الصاروخيه التي يشنها الجيش
اليمني اليمن ليس قوه عسكريه كبرى ولكنه
يمتلك اسلحه بمواصفات وقدرات تجعل من
الصعب ايقافها الجغرافيا والتضاريس تلعب
الى جانب اليمنيين فمثلا طول مضيق باب
المندب الخاص بالتجاره العالميه يبلغ نحو
113 را مع عرض 32 كيلومترا ما يجعله ضمن
نطاق سهل للصواريخ المضاده للسفن
والطائرات المسي وحتى مدافع الهاوتزر التي
تطلق قذائف بعيده المدى ويمكن تعقب السفن
بواسطه رادار ارضي فقط كما يمتلك الحوثيون
انواعا متعدده من الطائرات المسيره
والصواريخ البالستيه القاتله للسفن معظمها
من ايران بالاضافه الى نماذج سوفيتيه
وصينيه قديمه ويطلقون صواريخهم من قذيفه
متنقله يمكنها تغيير مواقعها بسرعه قبل ان
تتمكن مدمرات وبارات البحريه الامريكيه من
تحديد مواق الاطلاق وضربها بصاروخ كروز
وتوما هوك اي ان الصواريخ اليمنيه تحقق
اهدافها قبل ان ترد البحريه الامريكيه
بصواريخ توماهوك وبذلك فصو اليمنيين اسرع
من التوماهوك
الامريكي خبره عسكريه
كبيره صار لدى الجيش اليمني رصيد خبرات
عسكريه وتكتيكات تراكمت خلال سنوات طويله
من الحروب والمعارك وتاريخ حروب جيش صنعاء
يثبت ان الضربات الجويه وحدها لا يمكن ان
تحقق الانتصار وانما هناك حاجه لقوات
وقواعد على الارض فهل تتدخل الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا بريا في اليمن انه امر
يصعب تحقيقه وتخشاه الولايات المتحده وغير
موجود في خزينه اهدافها العسكريه في ظل
التضاريس والجغرافيا اليمنيه الصعبه بين
جبال شاهقه واراض وعرا قاسيه وضد كل من
ياتي من
الخارج خيارات واشنطن
ولندن البحر الاحمر هو الخط الاحمر
بالنسبه لليمنيين حتى تتحقق شروطهم الجيش
اليمني شن اكثر من 100 عمليه على سفن
الامريكان والانجليز والسفن المتجهه
للعبري في باب المندب الذي يمر منه اكثر
من 10 ملايين نفط وغاز يوميا نعم لقد
اجبرت امريكا على التدخل وبسرعه ولكن ليس
امام واشنطن سوى ثلاث خيارات الخيار الاول
ان تقبل بالامر الواقعي وتغير مسار السفن
لان التك تكلفه العاليه لصد اي مسيره او
صاروخ يمني غير منطقيه حيث تبلغ قيمه
الصاروخ او المسيره نحو 10 الاف دولار اقل
من ذلك او اكثر بقليل بينما تبلغ تكلفه
الصاروخ الذي يسقطها نحو مليوني دولار
الخيار الثاني ضرب مواقع اطلاق الصواريخ
والمسيرات لكن بسبب الجغرافيا اليمن
والتضاريس الصعبه سيجعل من الصعب العثور
على مواقع الاطلاق الخيار الثالث وهو ترك
الامر للحظ بانتظار توسع الحلف معلن عنه
في البحر الاحمر والذي لم تنضم له دول
عالميه كثيره والسؤال المهم هنا هو هل
سيدفع الغرب ضريبه تامين البحر الاحمر ام
سينتظر الغربيون التدخل الصيني في الحقيقه
فقد لجات الولايات المتحده الى التنين
الصيني راجيه من بيكين كبح جماح ابو اليمن
لكن ان استجابت الصين للطلب الامريكي فما
هو المقابل الذي سيحصل عليه اصحاب العيون
الضيقه اذا فالخسار بكل الطرق تجد طريقها
نحو واشنطن
فاده حرب
الحلفاء تحالف اليمن مع روسيا وكما يقول
المثل عدو عدو صديقي ومثلما دعمت امريكا
واوكرانيا وادخلت روسيا في حرب استنزاف
اليوم استدعت روسيا الحوثي لدعمه لقطع اخر
شريان للتجاره والغرب انصار الله الحوثيين
وصلوا موسكو هناك في وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه جلس قاده صنعاء ويقابلهم قاده روس
كان الحديث الرسمي عن مباحثات لضروره
تكثيف الجهود الدوليه للضغط على امريكا
وتل ابيب لوقف الحرب على القطاع مع ادانه
القصف الامريكي البريطاني لليمن لكن ما
ذهبت اليه تقرر اعلاميه ومراكز تحليل
سياسيه وعسكريه كان اكثر من الحديث عن
مباحثات ادانه او شجب بكثير بل تعدتها
لكشف مناقشات حول حضور روسي مفاجئ في
البحر الاحمر قد ياتي على شكل قاعده
عسكريه روسيه في اليمن او صفقه اسلحه
صاروخيه ومسيرات بحريه وجويه سيحتاجها
اليمن الذي بات شوكه تنغص على على امريكا
ومعها كل الغرب في البحر الاحمر فاذا
استطاعت موسكو ادخال واشنطن في حرب
استنزاف مع اليمن فاليمن معروفون منذ
الازل برباط شاشم وقوتهم في الحروب واليمن
مقبره للغزاه كما يقال ولنا في حرب
اليمنيين مع العثمانيين وحربهم مع الحبشه
وحربهم مع الفرس خير دليل حتى انهم اي
اليمنيون كادوا ان يدخلوا حربا مع جن
سليمان فقد قالها مستشار سباء يقول تعالى
ذكره في معنى الايه القرانيه قال الملا من
قوم ملكه سباء اذ شاورت في امرها وامر
سليمان نحن ذو القوه على القتال والباس
الشديد في الحرب والامر ايتها الملكه اليك
في القتال وفي تركه فانظري في الراي ما
ترين ف مورنا نا تمر لامريكي ان اردت حربا
فنحن لها وسنقف امام جن سليمان وجيشه يقف
اليمن امام اقوى دول العالم اليوم ببضعه
صواريخ ومسيرات فهل بامكان اليمن ان يفعل
ما هو اكثر من ذلك لو امتلكوا اسلحه اقوى
الاجابه لكم متابعينا